now you've said that a second referendum
is on Scottish independence is now
within touching distance so how quickly
do you think it could happen I want it
to happen next year and the reason for
that is simple I believe it's time for
Scotland to determine what kind of
future we want and what kind of country
we want to be in in effect who decides
Scotland's future is one of the central
questions at this general election we
can leave our future in the hands of
Boris Johnson be taken out of the EU
against I will have our NHS and water
rights put at the mercy of Donald Trump
continue down a path that sees tax cuts
for the wealthiest prioritized over
investment in public services and people
or we can take our future into our own
hands and choose a Scotland that is open
and welcoming where we put fairness and
equality very much at the heart of
everything that we do so that's the the
question for people in Scotland at this
election it really matters our future is
on the lane and it's a choice of what
came to future we want we heard from
Boris Johnson a little earlier on the
show I'm not sure if you managed to
catch his entire replying but some of
the question when I asked if he would be
prepared to give the green light to
another independence referendum he said
he doesn't want to have one he doesn't
see any reason to go back on that that
people have already had their say in a
once-in-a-generation event what did you
make of his answer well I thought his
waffling was quite instructive actually
I mean he committed to recognize the
fact that many things have changed since
Scotland had an independence referendum
in 2014 not least we face been taken out
of the EU against our will but he said
he didn't want another referendum he
said he opposed independence actually
that's perfectly legitimate I don't
agree with it but it's legitimate but I
thought it was interesting that he
stopped short of saying that he would
seek to block the rate of the Scottish
people to choose and when you think
about it maybe that's not surprising
because when he does see that
particularly the start of an election
campaign he sounds as if he's seen to
the Scottish people that he doesn't care
how we vote he's going to ignore that
vote no the fact of the matter is that's
not a sustainable position it's
certainly not a democratic position
everybody in Scotland knows there's
going to be another independence
referendum
people of Scotland vote SNP year for the
SNP win this election then that sends a
clear message that we want to take our
future into our own hands rather than
have Boris Johnson continue to impose a
future upon us and Jeremy Corbyn of
course is the other person who perhaps
has got the best chance of ending up at
number 10 Downing Street after the
election if you had any conversations
with anyone from Labour about whether
they could grant any second independence
referendum I've had conversations with
Jeremy Corbyn recently they've tended to
focus on brakes that we've not had a
direct conversation about independence
or an independence referendum I think
Jeremy Corbyn like Boris Johnson is well
aware of my position and my party's
proposition or not again jeremy corbyn's
position on this and our new great fan
of Jeremy Corbyn has been a lot more
democratic and sensible than his party
colleagues in Scotland again he's saying
he doesn't want a referendum he doesn't
support independence but he believes
it's for the people of Scotland to say
that question not for Westminster
politicians to stand in its way and that
is of course the fundamental issue we
can disagree on what the best future for
Scotland is I passionately believe that
that is as an independent country
charting our own course working with
others across the UK Europe and further
afield others can take a different view
but the people who should decide that
question are people here in Scotland and
if Derek Rubin has told me before that
it's something that he wouldn't agree to
in the first few years if you like if a
Labour government I mean it's not
something you could live with it not
happening immediately given it might end
up normally that you you know I I think
these questions whether there is another
independence referendum or not and what
the timescale of that should be are
questions for the Scottish people and
the Scottish Parliament to decide I'm
put in a very clear proposition before
the Scottish people in this general
election and definites and F of course I
take nothing for granted
if the SNP win that election then for
any Westminster politician to seek to
stand in the way of an independence
referendum on that time scale would be
seeking to ignore the democratically
expressed wishes of the
Scottish people that is not a
sustainable position it's not a
democratic position and as that happens
I don't think it is a position that any
Westminster politician will be able to
stick to you talk about democracy a lot
in this interview I just can't help
thinking you know the SNP want a second
Scottish independence referendum you
didn't like the result the first of all
and you want a second referendum or
brexit because you didn't like the
result with the first one I mean how
many referendums do you need to see
before you accept what people are
telling you well the UK's had a mace
that's not my fault and it has to work
its way out of that mace no let me just
take on a couple of the I guess
insinuations in that question yes that's
absolutely true I didn't like the result
of the 2014 referendum I wish it had
gone differently but I accepted that
result Scotland is not independent today
I simply take the view that particularly
given everything that's happened since
in any democracy people have a right to
change their minds and as far as the
brexit vote is concerned Scotland 42
remained so all I'm trying to do on
breaks it is to stand up for how people
in Scotland voted we want to remain part
of the European family of Nations and we
don't think the EU is perfect but we
understand the benefits they come from
that we don't want Scotland to turn away
from that we don't want to be close we
don't want to be seen to be unwelcoming
to those who come to our country from
elsewhere with a an open inclusive
welcoming country and that's how we want
to steer for Scotland is independent we
continue to be the best of friends and
neighbors to the other parts of the
British Isles but we can also continue
to make our contribution and play a full
part in the European Union and further
afield that's the kind of
internationalism that is at the very
heart of the Scottish independence
movement so if Scotland and did have a
second independence referendum and voted
to leave would you like to see a
confirmatory referendum once the terms
of the deal and the terms the departure
were made clearly like you want to see
in brexit no and I don't believe that we
should equate the two things I don't
believe that that is an inevitable part
of any democratic referendum process the
problem with breaks it is
nobody was straight in advance of the
referendum a bit what it meant there was
no detail it wasn't at the kind of
informed decision that the 2014
independence referendum was it's I
oppose brakes as I think you've probably
gathered but there was nothing
inevitable about the mace that breaks
that has become by contrast in 2014 of
course people took different views but
there was a detailed prospectus put
forward people were very informed about
the choices they were making a lot of
thought had gone into at the compromises
and the trade-offs that would be
required of Scotland voltage is one of
the most controversial parts of the yes
campaigns proposition was a currency
union seeing upfront that that was one
of the trade-offs that we would seek to
bring a boat so these two things are not
the same I would always want a Scottish
independence referendum to be informed
with a lot of detail so that people were
taking a careful and considered decision
so let's not assume that the mace breaks
it has become and some of what might be
required now to get out of that mace is
an inevitable part of a democratic
process because it is not that's the
failure of the politicians who put
forward that leaf prospectus and the
ones that Aliza me who tried to
implement it without recognizing that
she was putting forward a lot of
contradictory red lines in the process
I'm keen to talk to you as well just has
been kind of finished up about the
election that we are fighting imminently
if you like and what would be a good
night for the SNP well look I don't put
an upper limit on the ambitions of my
party we fight we had a national party
we will fight in every corner of
Scotland and every constituency of
Scotland but I also take nothing for
granted I mean we sometimes forget all
of us media and indeed my own party that
before 2015 the biggest number of MPs
that the SNP had ever had at one time
was 11 we've now got 35 so of course we
want to increase that tally but it's a
difficult thing to do so we'll be
fighting hard for every vote every
constituency pulling forward a very
strong prospectus about the future of
Scotland and the need to be the ones and
the driving seat of deciding that future
and then we'll trust the people of
Scotland to vote in the way that's best
for the future of Scotland